well thank you everyone for being here
today we are just thrilled with the
crowd and so excited to have the speed
for the day it's my pleasure to
introduce and moderate our first panel
of the day which we're calling the
scholarly perspective and we are lucky
enough to have three faculty members
from Columbia from across the
disciplines to share with us some of
their perspectives and thoughts on the
things that we're hearing this morning
and and really about the changing nature
of research as we're seeing that happen
before us some music in the background
when we have the faculty in the room you
never know what's going to happen it's
it's fantastic um I should thank them
even more for being here is our spring
break here and so they are giving up one
of their very valuable spring break
mornings to be with us so the structure
the panel will be as follows I'm going
to introduce all of our panelists and
then I'm going to sit down with them and
really facilitate a conversation I have
a few prepared questions that I'll kick
things off with and then we really want
to open this up to the audience and get
a dialogue going here so with that I'm
going to introduce first Susan boyton
she is a professor of music here and she
joined the Colombian faculty in two
thousand her current research interests
include liturgy in music in medieval
Western monasticism particularly abbey
of Cluny manuscript studies monastic
education and music in the Iberian
Peninsula professor Boynton is currently
the chair of Columbia the columbia
university seminar on medieval studies
and she serves on the editorial boards
of the Journal of the American Music
illogical society the Journal of
medieval Iberian studies studies in
iconography and is one of the book
reviewers for speculum mark Hanson who
was at the end there is join Columbia
Journalism school angel July 2012 after
a decade of shuttling between west and
east coasts in LA he held appointments
in the Department of Statistics the
department of design media arts in the
Department of Electrical Engineering at
UCLA literally forming a triangulation
of data are in technology and was a co
bi for the Center for embedded networked
sensing an NSF science and
do center devoted to the study of sensor
networks he holds a PhD in MA and
statistics from the University of
California Berkeley and an MS n abs in
applied math from UC Davis Chris Wiggins
who's in the middle here speaking on
behalf of the sciences is a associate
professor of applied math at Columbia
and holds a PhD in theoretical physics
from Princeton his research centers on
Big Data in the Natural Sciences
developing machine learning and
statistical inference methods for making
sense of sequence in network data in
physics and biology he's the faculty
representative for the chapter Columbia
chapter of the society for industrial
and applied math and he's a co-founder
of hack New York gorg which organizes
student hackathons and summer
internships here for the next generation
of NYC technologists so with that I
think what I'm going to do is just throw
the first question and then have each of
you respond and then I'll join you at
the table and that first question is to
have each of you just briefly describe
your field of research and how research
methodologies or practices need
discipline have changed in the last five
to ten years and how you are responding
to those changes and should i do I need
to turn this honors it seems me I'm okay
great so I think of myself as basically
a historian oops beautiful yeah I'll
foreclosure sorry oh I think of myself
basically as a historian so although I'm
in the music department my work is very
historical I'm a medievalist and so I
work quite a bit across disciplines and
but anyway speaking as a historian I
found that the survey of the Ithaca
survey really represented well my own
thoughts and my own circumstances my
research tends to work across different
geographic regions and also different
disciplines such as our history theology
liturgy social history church history
and and not to mentioned music and so as
a medievalist we tend to use a lot of
unpublished sources and a lot of texts
text editing and data analyzing
technique
and the way that the field has changed
in recent years is really of course
heavy digitization and also innovative
tools for searching for cross database
searching many there are many tools that
are library specific that our
subscription databases and then there
are many that are actually publicly
available for various reasons because
their funding to their open Internet
resources that are government-funded
projects from different places and I
want to put in a plug that medievalists
have actually been in the vanguard of
the digital humanities for the past 30
years so many of the really big projects
are many lists projects one of them is
the digital scriptorium here at columbia
one of the best known in the world that
puts columbia on the map from many
places that do not know what columbia is
they know the digital scriptorium and
other ones are things that may sound
very arcane to you things that are large
growing databases with the inventories
of the contents of the Turgeon whole
manuscript that enable you to search and
identify some families or strands or
commonalities so one of the big trends
is with this huge availability of
digitized manuscripts through the
national libraries and through private
libraries as well three digital
scriptorium which you know has many
different libraries represented and
other kinds of databases one of the big
trends is to gather much more precise
and nuanced information about physical
object so for instance i'm sitting in
colombia's Rare Book and Manuscript
library with a manuscript and I'm able
to much more quickly to reach
conclusions about the date the origin of
the manuscript other features of the
manuscript through comparative sources
but I has to be a combination of the
physical artifact the physical piece of
information with the various resources
at my disposal and this is this is the
sort of foremost trend I think now the
questions are not necessarily the new
new questions it's a new way of
answering the old questions with greater
accuracy and the other thing is that now
as was already mentioned this morning
that there's greater digital capture
allowed in
on libraries and Archives there's grow
much greater responsibility or should we
say obligation for researchers to have
control of their of their data and to
have captured huge numbers of images for
comparative purposes so basically things
like the imaging and image control image
archiving image manipulation etc is
extremely important in Medieval Studies
and specifically in my own fields as
well so basically there's an explosion
of his of interest right now not only in
medieval but I think in pretty much
anything that could be called pre-modern
maybe maybe up to 1800 and maybe beyond
1800 in the physical text in the in the
object itself whether it's a printed
book or manuscript or something else and
I what I see at large I mean this is
these things are being funded by the
mellon Foundation by the ACLS you know
everybody many of the people getting big
grants are many lists and because there
is a sense of the importance of of
confronting the physical object in the
larger digital environment and
understanding in fetters so I think the
last thing I was going to say is that I
think that that is the focus now is the
understanding that with the greater
availability of digital information on
early collections actually the focus on
the early collections themselves has has
multiplied in many many many times and
that's something that's very important
for libraries to understand it's not as
if or we can just go and look at
pictures of things on the intranet it's
actually the opposite we're going to use
those pictures to look at our own things
in our own libraries where we are
situated physically and facilitate our
use of physical collections in other
places in the world and for that reason
I'll talk about this afterwards my own
teaching for especially for graduate
students but increasingly in other ways
too is completely focused on special
collections so I teach my graduate
seminar in Rare Book and Manuscript
library every single week we look at
manuscripts every single week all the
workshops I organized for graduate
students involve looking at rare rare
books in the rebel commander
so I think that's I would really second
the fact that of the statement by Roger
that um this has to be part of the
training graduate students they have to
learn they can't just be you know sent
off somewhere to figure it out by
themselves which many which is a very
venerable tradition in historical go to
Europe for the Fulbright and they say
you know my first six months were spent
trying to figure out what the hell I was
doing how to read the documents that I
went to Europe to read this cannot
happen anymore you know the funding
models do not do this so basically do a
lot of this in our classes talk too long
is it good thank you thank you for going
Chris I'm Chris Wiggins I am an applied
physicist applied mathematician with PhD
in theoretical physics my research is in
machine learning applied to
computational biology so the projects
that I've been interested in and have
done research on that sort of spanned
multiple paradigms of doing science I
was really raised doing scientific
computation which is sometimes referred
to as in third paradigm of doing
research after experiment and
theoretical or mathematical modeling
it's been an exciting time to have
technology change my research and the
research of my collaborators over the
last decade or two in many ways
including that in in the mid-90s say
entire genomes of organisms were being
sequence so a wealth of data was being
produced an astronomical amount of data
by biological standards of biological
abundance of data by astronomical
standards but it really changed the way
people working upon modeling and biology
working biology became massively
data-driven and entered what sometimes
is now called a fourth paradigm a way of
doing science in which the data outstrip
your ability to form hypotheses the data
outstrip your ability even to decide
what are the appropriate models as you
attempt to learn those models from the
data statistical tools in the Natural
Sciences which has been very new so
again part of that week Mike please oh
please yes sorry thank you so part of
that was in the in the 90s the
sequencing of whole organisms but
coincidentally in the mid 90s people
started using the internet facilitated
by the World Wide Web to share their
data rapidly so part of the transition
in my research in the last two decades
has been an abundance of data but also
the cultural change that you are
expected to share your data and that the
scientific change this world
paradigmatic change that you will use
those data to drive your research data
driven research has now become a thing
the idea being that the daily um first
even before the hypotheses that the
technologies will allow you to generate
data particularly in biology and then
decide what it is that you will find how
you build interpretable and predictive
models from that and how you answer
questions from the Natural Sciences so
that's been disruptive and exciting and
fun along with that I has come a change
as biology has become a computational
field in how we think about
reprehensibility which has been a
cornerstone of science since the 18th
century and it's challenged when
people's research becomes a
computational algorithm executed on a
particular data set and as a particular
computational algorithms become grease
progressively more complicated there
comes a breaking point in a field and
certainly it's been seen in biology at
which your publications are no longer
reprimand it needs the tree so biology
as has experienced that pain point where
you have papers that are the most
anointed celebrated papers of the field
but really you know produce methods
which cannot be reproduced either
because the data sets themselves are not
liberating do not appear in line or the
algorithm is sufficiently complicated
that even trust me when you read the
papers hundreds of times you will not be
able to understand let alone code that
is to do the research right in the same
way that as an experimentalist builds an
apparatus
it takes care of that apparatus a
computational scientist builds a code
base and maintains it takes care of that
code base and computational science and
biology has reached a breaking point
where the way we organize scientific
computation which is around a finite
discrete and dead tree of a piece of
paper which is the knowledge you know
laid dead is not enough for you to
reproduce the research that was actually
done and that has been a challenge that
biology is faced now I come to you as
the ghost of science future my claim and
this is not a kind I'm the only person
to share is that that pain point at
which biology becomes computational and
therefore in pain and suffering from the
inability to publish reproduce Lee in
the way that you know the great ones
told us to do in the 18th century is a
pain point that will be faced by every
field of science and possibly every
field of human endeavor human endeavor
as your field becomes computational
and/or data-driven for both that is
there comes a point where the
computation is part of your research and
computation the ability to reproduce a
computation is rarely facilitated by
four pages of dead tree right there's
more that needs to be communicated and
so I think technology challenges for us
how we take information in how we takes
a couple of scholarship in right and
that there's an overwhelming abundance
of it and it needs to be somehow
filtered and digested but also is
challenging how the information goes out
from our research groups and that we
need to rethink what we mean by
publication and the way that we share
science right so like when the activity
we now identify a science started being
identified as science and the hundreds
of years ago right it was largely about
people communicating the results and so
I wish for a sort of neoclassical you
know return to the part where we are
communicating the results in ways that
we will be able to reproduce and you
know four pages of dead tree is not
necessarily the right format for the
next set
I think also there's a role for
technology and funding the funding
landscape is dynamic chaotic
unpredictable right this I think today
the government is going to shut down
again and I think this week it was
announced that the NSF would because of
political actions cease to find you know
some fraction of its intellectual fields
and it is difficult for people who do
multi dip multidisciplinary research to
plan for the future and that includes
training young people for the future in
an environment that is so chaotic a
dynamic and so it's difficult to make
sense of finding information which is
what particularly for the last half
century has made science go in this
country and so I think there's a road
trip technology and helping get the
right people to the right information
about the right potential resources
which was mentioned by at least one of
the previous speakers not having
prepared remarks I'm not sure if I
reached the end but I think so my name
is mark Hanson um I'm in the School of
Journalism now my training though is in
statistics I was a statistics professor
at UCLA for about 10 years and was it
bell laboratories for about 10 years
before that I deal in data that's my
that's what I do and when I teach a
statistics to students it is really
teaching them about data and the way
that data operate in society the way
that knowledge is built around data the
processes by which we collect and curate
data and nowadays well perhaps when I
first started teaching and maybe this
was just because when you first start
teaching you suck at it but when I first
started teaching it felt pretty it felt
like a pretty easy thing there were some
data sets in the back of a book you know
Fisher was pretty good at giving us data
in the 20 so we could look at some of
that um there was some maybe some data
from a consulting project I looked at
and
and it was awful in time I've come to
realize that that the data thing that we
do is data stations is a thing that
every discipline does or is soon to do
as Chris mentioned every discipline the
core of almost the core artifacts of
almost every discipline are being
digitized in some way which renders them
as data which means they are computable
and as a statistician that means that my
practice should be expected expansive
one and not simply falling back on the
whole old hypothesis testing regime that
where it probably made many of you
unhappy in your introductory statistics
classes but instead look look out to
other disciplines for the lessons that
we can learn look out to geography and
learn about GIS look out to architecture
and how shape of code and the type of
data that are used to support those
practices are are affecting the look and
the feel of buildings to look at design
to look at art history to look at
English to look at every discipline as
it has its data moment not to say hey we
have principal components in the t-test
you should come here but instead learn
about their problems and the questions
and the individual disciplinary ethics
and values that are inflecting the
technologies that they are developing to
deal with with data in some way and so
as a as an instructor in statistics my
role was to bring that in to the
statistics department so my last year
UCLA I let our seminar series it had
been dominated the previous year well we
don't need to go in the previous year
but my ear was we had journalists
architects people from the digital
humanities people that left the students
excited to be in the discipline to think
about the potential that data had left
though many of my colleagues wondering
what we do about this when they were
maybe more invested in delta's and
epsilon and that sort of thing so my
research done over the last five years
has expanded because the character and
the nature and the role that data play
in the Academy and out in society has
radically changed and so so the ways in
which data circulate the ways in which
we talk about data the with the ways in
which
compute with and share those
computations are all all parts of my
practice that that have changed within
statistics at the same time you've also
had any I believe in increasing respect
for computation as and data analysis has
an exercise in the field you may not be
aware but statistics has a chip on its
shoulder about mathematics and often
thinks of itself as a can think of
itself as a branch of mathematics in my
mind that's a very dangerous place to go
because statistics left without
application and data is a very ugly
thing and so we're seeing increasingly a
respect for data analysis and and encode
but what that mean what that respect for
code means or that respect for data
analysis means is that that functions of
the discipline like tenure like
publication also have to have respect
for those for those exercises and that
we have to have publication standards
for those what does it mean to publish
code how do you credit it my personal
feeling is that every piece of software
you put out there should count for to
public hate but you come up with and
come up with a arithmetic later but but
um so there's there's the idea that code
and data are becoming more respected and
less transparent and I think that that's
something that maybe goes to chris's
point about reproducibility there's a
certain especially ironically in the
computational field I know I learned
computation because my advisor said
here's the book it was a Fortran here
learn to code do your thing right and
the bad first it communicates well this
isn't something we're going to take the
time to teach you so there really isn't
anything good to do here is just
something you do but then secondly you
don't have an opportunity to learn any
of the best practices and so the code
that I wrote was god-awful and so so so
there's that how how how things have
changed I think that the second thing I
wanted to mention unless I'm going to
shut up this because i have no internal
clock I apologize and I'm also just
getting off the plane from Rio sorry
we opening a global center in rio
columbia exercise it wasn't my fault
Patrick from copper ingots but anyway um
so uh oh this is being videos forever
and ever okay yeah that's true alright
so um the last I guess the last point as
I said I was trained as a statistician I
now have an appointment in the School of
Journalism I am technically the David
and Helen Gurley Brown professor of
journalism and I'll eat something called
the brown Institute which we can talk
about later but what what what I chose
this position or I grateful to have been
offer this position because not only has
data leached out to other parts of the
Academy but it's in society and data are
actively changing systems of power in
our society and someone has to know what
all of that amounts to so there's a move
to the public a move of data out into
the public and in the journalism school
I teach a class the spring called
journalistic computing or I'm teaching
25 journalists and 10 journalist author
auditors how to how to work with think
through build to build in to build
encode and this this this transition to
the journalism school while I suppose
contemporaneous with ships in data has
changed my practice because suddenly I
have to think about this expanded
practice of what it means to tell
stories with data the nature of evidence
how code fits into it how algorithm fits
into it how some of the basic core parts
of my training work in in a journalistic
context for example Chris mentions
reproducibility in a journalism and sort
of data journalism the the code word
there is transparency being able to make
sure that what you've done is is can be
taken up by someone else that you've
described it transparently enough that
someone can see exactly what you've done
to be able to to be able to
to recreate it but it goes beyond just
describing what you did in journalism we
are also imagining stories I've always
imagined stories circulating in one form
or another they're out in the public the
public takes it up interacts with them
does the public take data from us we
many journalistic institutions publish
ap is now what what are the ethics and
good practices for that how should we be
teaching our students to make a person
to think around those around those terms
so it's beyond reproducibility but it's
also in thinking about how these newly
published objects circulate accumulate
new data accumulate new experience and
how do they offer let's all stop there
great thank you that's great contact
setting this son okay um so I think
we'll segue to a question that focuses a
little bit on the library in terms of
that and then discussion so we're
interested in what what you see is the
role of the library in your research if
you if you see a role for the library at
all and and what services are assistance
do you feel you need in support of your
research given this this landscape that
you're describing so do what do we do
the same order okay so I was randomized
oh right so for me the library is kind
of where I live on campus both mentally
and and and physically and so I I see
the library partly as a place of
acquisitions for my needs so I need a
lot of formats as a musicologist you
know I need recordings I can affect
similes and collected editions of music
scores collected editions of texts
journals modern books I need of early
printed books i need manuscripts which
they actually acquire sometimes for me
to use for teaching and research i need
editing software through digital
humanities which what used to be called
electronic text services i need all the
subscription databases that help me do
my research is so that all those aspects
of the line idea i need Burke I need the
Union Theological Seminary library I
need Avery library I need the
non-circulating I need the circulating
on you borrow direct and you just
so from that aspect of the library's is
very very very important for me it would
be I mean you know it's sort of the
reason I would want to stay at Columbia
if I had opportunities to go elsewhere
and basically that means that i like to
see a robust acquisitions budget for
physical objects as well as for the
databases i like to have creative
strategy which have we have had to
deploy on occasion for the goals of
acquisitions that i have had I've made
use of and relationships with the
subject specialists and curators and so
the people in the library are absolutely
crucial to me for my route I also see a
lot of overlap between my teaching in my
research and so my relationships with
the subject specialists and the curators
um enlighten archives and in rare books
are absolutely crucial to my daily life
basically and um so I guess also even
even in terms of publication Special
Collections can offer images and
permissions for publications which is
very important and it for my own
intellectual kind of development
stimulation presentation things like the
series that the library has the history
of the book series other lecture series
that have taken place in the library are
very important for me personally for
developing also my research interest so
I kind of see a big panorama I
collaborate with certain specific
specialists here for instance constable
of Dutch kima can't be here today
because she's not well she and I have
collaborated that we're now working on
our second exhibition together of
medieval manuscripts and so I i really
think that the libraries have that world
to play in the life of the faculty who
are interested in in the wide range of
resources that I am interested in um I
have a long-standing relationship with
libraries and with Columbia in
particular I arrived here in the 1980s
as an undergraduate from Texas wearing
white sneakers
mullet I went into Butler and I smelled
the stacks and I wandered the slacks of
Butler and I discovered that there were
stacks and stacks of books about things
that I did not even know you were
allowed to study as academic subjects so
I have long-standing relationship which
really with libraries in graduate school
when normal people were spent their
afternoons outside playing I was with de
science Citation Index which people who
are watching on the internet may not
know used to be a physical thing shelves
and shelves of orange and yellow books
and if you wanted to find papers that
cited other papers you would go find
that book and you would flip through in
a little teeny pop font can tell you
other papers on that subject right mind
blowing if you now use google for tort
bing or whatever you use um and that is
why it pains me to say that i don't
think i've walked into a physical
library to help my research in years I I
love interlibrary loan I love going
through columbia's library proxy in
order sometimes to download electronic
journals of papers electronic versions
of papers many times google scholar is
rendering even that I'm needed because
someone somewhere if it's a good paper
has put that PDF on the course website
or their personal website and google
scholar will find it and download it
without entering my credentials so my
relationship with libraries as a
research tool has changed quite a bit it
in part because of google scholar and
and google tools more generally as was
mentioned in a prior talk i'm still
loving interlibrary loan on occasion but
I I'm rarely reading a research book you
know I
somebody's very recent paper or I want
somebody's very recent data very recent
code I might send my students to go read
a book and in fact even some of the best
books are books that the author's
themselves simply give away right on
their websites right ESL one of the
standard books of statistics is well
known to be simply distributed by the
authors on their website so i used to
have a copy which I kept losing because
I kept giving it to students because it
was such a good book and now I just give
them the URL okay an interlibrary loan
you know I'll read it for something
historical not necessarily something
directly related to my research that's
it I love it sort of the netflix style
of library book is out there somewhere
in somebody else's librarian I don't
need it right now and I'm frankly more
than happy to have it simply mailed
directly to my building rather than
having to go over to Butler search for
it somewhere so it's okay with me for
the books to be in jersey or in
Minnesota or wherever they need to be so
that they will eventually show up at my
building um yeah so I would say that
that is my that is my research with the
physical that is my relationship with
the physical library present uncle so I
should preface this with I've only been
here seven months and I still have five
overdue books at ucla's which I think I
probably doesn't pay to replace but you
know before I came over here I was
talking to my colleague Emily Bell about
you know that I was going to spend a bit
of this afternoon talking about
libraries and and I'm not quite sure
what I would have what I what I need
from a physical library anymore and we
got into this discussion about the
relationship that no journalism I you
may or may not know is going through a
bit of a crisis at the moment and and
part of journalism's problem was that it
confused people's desire for information
with the fact that the paper controlled
the channel of the information right so
the the information versus the control
of the information
right and it wasn't that people were
necessarily thinking the New York Times
had righteous content which it does but
it was also that it controlled the
channel through which him and there's
some parallel there with a physical
library controlling channel but at the
same time it's funny that you brought up
the sort of sensory when I was at Bell
Laboratories the library there i would
spend i would leave my office and do
work down there in part because it
smelled like history like it smelled it
had a feeling in a gravity to it you
just couldn't get away from but in
addition to that there's a physical
something or there's there's something
to physical archives that when you're
walking down and this is things you know
well but when you're walking down you
know an aisle and a book catches your
eye or it's the thing behind you write
the book on the shelf behind the book
that you're supposed to have or you know
my took my students on a tour of the
morgue at the new york times right up to
the mid 90s that was as active clipping
practice and huge rooms of these you
know card catalog type things if you
want to find out about Bill Clinton you
would pull it out and you take out this
little bit and undo the twine and you'd
spread out all of the clippings and the
the person of the more said you know
couldn't tell me how many times the the
next step for the recorder was following
a lead that was on the back of the story
he was supposed to be looking at right
there's something about that physical
thing right it's oh yeah this is a
serendipity word right but but what's
interesting is that that serendipity was
happening he couldn't really describe
why like what that was what that was
doing right it's not that we laid out
you know the library in a particular I
mean yeah there's a whole Dewey Decimal
what's this right and yes the back of
the the back of a newspaper is still got
an article that's of the same moment as
the one on the other side but it may be
a completely different topic or what
have you but but I don't know that we
understand what made that happen it's
just interesting that it's that it
happened right there was physical
serendipity
this discovery process that doesn't
happen to me when I look at a google
search and I'm a little frightened to
try to explain to a computer scientist
what might be required to make that
Sarah did that happen so we optimized
serendipity like that feels like a wrong
direction to me but at the same time
there's something about alternate ways
to experience content or to surface
things that aren't just search driven
and maybe that's what I would look for
and again I'm not telling you anything
you don't know because everyone's
nodding like yeah the statistician
finally gets it but that's so my
relationship to the physical library
like Chris's has been a place for me
it's been a place of professional
validation I feel like I am somewhere
because I am where the smart people get
it right but then but then beyond that I
haven't checked out up except for the
five that are in my office till I
haven't checked out a book on the
library in a long time and mostly I take
all of the content online and I'm
grateful for the ease with which I can
navigate sort of that channel through
Columbia's negotiated contracts I would
say the only other thing is I know my
students and journalism depend on the
library for access to certain kinds of
data sets although some of the
interfaces there are a little clunky and
I prefer to have the actual data but
that's a whole other thing mark I'd like
you to expand on why you don't think
that why you don't believe that the
right algorithm or the right user
interface can create some of the
serendipity I mean as an example yeah
amazon amazon has a clear business
interest right they make more monies if
they successfully give you some amount
or serendipity so I mean are you saying
that that's failing or that somehow it
doesn't work in a research to somebody
in the same way I mean it's a it's a
it's a narrow I think the thing is that
that again the design of these physical
archives wasn't for serendipity it was
for access or you all could tell me that
so maybe it was it was all set up
Stephanie every time you walked in the
library
at the same time though I would imagine
that the life for the librarians the
optimization was to find your
information as quickly as possible and
scroll around into whatever right and
it's just because you had to physically
go past these other topics that this
happened but see that to me is not
implicit in the design of the system and
now if I try to switch that like I make
it a value and I fake it in okay I feel
like there's a part of that
serendipities is my humaneness coming to
this to this system and I don't know
that I want and it's also kids also
transparent I know what I'm doing I'm
walking through I'm i am moving through
I'm seeing something I'm looking to the
other side it's something on the back I
totally get it if it's a trick if it's a
look I've written more algorithms and I
know it's doing right so but I'm high I
kind of opaque algorithm that is
surfacing things in a way that I don't
necessarily understand like especially
if it's amazon and it's got it like
money at the bottom of it right I don't
I don't want this serendipity isn't
about me buying a book this their duties
we going oh that's I hadn't thought
about that before or oh that you said
the same thing you walk through and you
see all these have you ever had that at
amazon that moment like look at all
these topics that i could think about
and we're talking at the recommendations
that Amazon sends you you know that that
you go right it tells us a touch an
example of I just mean of one of myriad
examples of an interface where I search
for if ain maybe i mistyped it whatever
and then it shows me a bunch of other
things that you might like right and
cuddly they're dumb ways to do it and
what the algorithm doesn't know that my
grandmother had done this thing when I
was five years old and it led me to
think anybody fighter to do we needed
the fact that that looks for you know
and that's why said it had me it's
happening and how algorithm okay sorry
you're looking for I'm so we've got
about 15 20 minutes I'd love to open it
up to the audience for questions so I'm
gonna pass the mic off hi this question
is for Chris Wiggins and it's asked
partly out of ignorance of current
scientific theory and practice so okay
um you mentioned reproducibility as a
traditional standard of verifiability in
the sciences yes and I'm just wondering
you know in this world of big data and
data sets does is the standard of
reproducibility still viewed as the gold
standard and do we imagine that people
will prep on a prat in a practical sense
try and replicate results that were
derived from big data sets etc yes or is
the standard of reproducibility changing
somehow good so there at least two ways
of answering the question and they're
both know so the first way of answering
your question is is it the case that
scientists somehow are incentivized to
publish their work in a way that is
reprimand sir now there's there's no
intent to be like the goal is to get
large number of publications not for
those publications to be reproducible
and that is that is how you will get
promoted and retained or whatever in
academia not to be reproducible your
second way of answering your question is
is it the case that there exists a
standard of repartee no so people who
think clearly about this sudden earth
because think about it for about 15
minutes or maybe half an hour on a
afternoon when you have nothing else to
do and you'll realize you know Rep
reducibility does that mean that I
should share the code or the code and
the data or that I should share the code
and the data and make sure that the code
are written in an open source language
so that you can compile it on your
machine or you know in your machine may
run in some crazy way that you know I
have special needs on plus of my setup
on my machine that makes it impossible
for you to reproduce it right so so no
there's not one single standard
reproduce ability of should i create a
unique digital object identifier
associated with the Compendium if you
look at Gary Kings work he uses the word
compendium for the code and the data to
get it there's there's actually many
nuances to what constitutes rep
reducibility however the problem is like
the nuances are happening way over
yonder right the problem is nobody even
cares because the incentive structure
just does not identify people to be
reproducible whatsoever but I will agree
with you like look at Boyle right i mean
rep reducibility is not a new idea in
science right it's just that with every
field Vikram with every field I contend
that they will come a point where your
field becomes either computation driven
or data driven to the point where the
rep reducibility is thwarted by the act
of publishing which is what science has
become to be about right science is no
longer about you know Society of people
rotating somebody else's house in London
and opening up the dog's heart saying
here's how a dog's heart works right
it's now become about killing trees that
is the currency which agony trying to do
public a about and that is not a
currency in an mo that facilitates go to
the school well except the funding
organizations are starting to take up
the at least to a certain extent trying
to take up the lip service better than
nothing but not movie but I mean now the
magic word would have to go someone
would have to
sighs that system there's no there's two
there's a couple gatekeepers right
because there's the funders but there's
also the publishers right so look at
what happened with the protein database
in protein crystal structure right which
is an old field right like we used to
say biophysics you meant the shape of a
protein right what happened was in this
took decades for it to happen the
publishers the funding agencies the
editors of the big journals right
science major and paint ass got together
and said you will no longer be allowed
to publish a paper about a new crystal
protein structure if you do not put the
coordinates in the protein database and
that requires there to be the protein
database which itself required a bunch
of funders and other people to get
together so these things moved in
lockstep and it takes no change in
narrative the change in demands but
that's how sort of refugees ability is
is one is by fighting right and it
involves the people who control the
monies but also the people who control
the publications which is ultimately
controlling careers and the people with
the promotions right so that people who
are looking at promotion cases because
it does to be able to put code out there
and to write code in a certain way that
it takes time right so that litany and
papers that you've just described you
may only have we may do a third fewer of
them because suddenly now you have to
pay attention to how the code is written
and make sure that it's out there and so
on right so yes and that takes work
right because scholars have to be
willing when they are doing reviews and
promotion to actually read the papers
and as a scholar a colleague of mine put
it once the type that it's much easier
to count the to read right so when
you're reviewing somebody here you could
just count how many papers they have and
that's a lot harder than saying did they
produce something like I don't
understand or someone like general tool
that a lot of people use can use
um I'm from UCLA so I can take those
five books back so for those of you who
aren't visiting libraries physically
much anymore and and also for you who
live in the library maybe you can think
about the times that you're not
physically there if you could teleport a
librarian into your research process at
some point where would it be it depends
on what they're willing to do so I mean
there are ways in which i really need
help making my students become prepared
21st century scholars and i don't i
don't know if that's what librarians i
interested in doing or if I have yeah
I'm certainly not in the org chart of
Columbia tasked with telling them to do
that but I can certainly use how with
making my making my students fully
housebroken digital researchers for the
21st century but in digital publishers
right so if there was a way to lead and
to say this would help sort out that
reproducibility question or the
transparency question or however you
frame it to say this is what a righteous
act of computational publication looks
like right these are the standards and
this is how you cited and this is I like
that would all be the sort of thing that
that would be tremendous so for me it's
from it's sort of at all the stages
because I use reference services a lot i
work with librarians in music who are
very very helpful both for subject
specific and as reference librarians
generally and helping me guide you know
how guiding you through collections both
colombia's and the other related
collections the kind of the network of
how to deal with the networker navigate
the network and of collections and and
then in the middle of the process when I
have specific questions and then a lot
of the read the books each book I've
written I've needed Columbia to make
extensive acquisitions just a material
that I need so I'm working with the
subject specialists on what they can
acquire they have to get things that are
out of print you know I have to have a
long lead times and times for things and
then at the end for permissions the
production informations are working with
people also to have things
available to have things from off-site
removed permanently from off site in
some cases there's always the problem of
where things are permanently to have
yeah so every stage pretty much and I
mean a quite a many of the people in
this room I've worked with over the
years and they're essential partners for
me so I would say there's not really a
stage in which they're not part of my
process so as a librarian I would like
to say that we are here to help teach
those undergraduate students how to
research so I would love to know with
the students that you're working with
where is that big gap that you see what
are those big things that you think gosh
I just wish that they would come to
class understanding this about research
about and when I say data management I
don't necessarily mean the numbers but
you have you know the research journals
that they're looking at and data sets
and code and what is it that you just if
I could give them this or help them
understand this is how you write a paper
regardless of the sort of money that's
driving publishing but what's a few
things that you wish that they did know
I think can I answer that one first I
would I think the biggest problem now
for students is not knowing how to make
sense of what's available to them it
used to be Once Upon I've actually
stopped from any courses giving any kind
of research paper because not because
that their hope they're not hopeless
students they're quite good students in
many cases but the number of first of
all they may not have the languages but
even if they have the languages the
number of layers it would take of
experience for them to use sources
critically and I think it's not that
they're not critical thinkers but
there's there's so many resources to use
critically for them to learn how not to
rely on Wikipedia how not to rely on
uncritical types of resources it takes a
long time and I think it would be great
if in undergraduates all would have that
kind of training and experience I know
that in many
subjects at Columbia specific majors
they do have it at one stage they have
much more methods courses than we have
in music and are part of our problem is
music is interdisciplinary we have
ethnomusicologist composers theorists
and music historians and performers all
at the undergraduate level they're
already specializing in many cases so
we've never been able to figure out how
do you have something that will meet the
needs for that population all at once in
our history of course it's a different
thing they're studying our history it's
not quite the same so I'm in the same in
history and so on so anyway I think that
would be that's that there must be a way
to solve the problem but I think that's
the biggest for me that's the biggest
gap between what I would like the
students to be able to do and what
they're actually able to do ok that's
very hard to answer and part because it
depends on age in part because it become
it depends on discipline so for
undergraduates yes there are things like
how to use Wikipedia and how not to over
use Wikipedia and I'm i do I cannot tell
young people not to use Wikipedia
because I use Wikipedia right somebody's
gonna have no yeah and the first global
head or whatever is great to be i will
use wikipedia right so how to use it
responsibly is something to learn how to
use google scholar how to use science
citation index is you know in my field
becoming less relevant and Google
Scholar is becoming more relevant in
biology how did learn pubmed is
certainly part of becoming a properly
trained biologist and eventually how to
use google books and that's how you
might tell young people at some point
though they become graduate students and
then in my field i will tell them how to
use archive try to work and mostly
that's about how to bring in the
information but also when it comes time
to publish how are we going to use
archive org how to use google reader
soon-to-be rest in peace right which is
a large part of how i get information
about publications trends and funding
all sorts of things how to use those
sort of collaborative tools within your
group also i think is very important
because i'm in a computational field
software carpentry version control
and simply good hygiene about sharing
code and data computationally is really
central it just never taught just simply
not time despite the fact that all these
fields are becoming computational good
software carpentry is not taught and so
that's something that and again speaking
as ghost of Christmas future I pretend
that that is going to become relevant to
more and more fields but those general
sort of collaborated tools also I mean
something like a journal club should not
only happen once a week when you can
physically get together right so my
group has been very good my students i
should say i do nothing my students of
course are the ones who have taught me
everything about how to use google
reader or any other tool for learning
each other day we're seeing in
publications and I wouldn't echo the
piece about code and the and sort of
knowing knowing how to write code to
publish date in a way that can be can be
shared and reused what sorts of I you
know what sorts of agreements have to be
struck what does it mean to put data out
there I mean I think some of that's the
reason you don't get more data put out
is for those little for the for the for
the just because it's not sort of clear
what what all that what you end up
supporting and what all that means so
the the other thing I think just least
sticking with journalism I know that the
students need to be able to get a sense
of what what data are out there about
about um I mean their beats are
typically somewhere in New York City so
what data are out there about New York
what data out there period and not data
that are kind of locked up that's behind
pulldown menus that are not very
expressive you know I had a sad in a
reporting class because I'm not a
journalist and suddenly I'm in a
journalism school so to try to figure
out what what they're teaching in
reporting classes and they had just this
one pretty cool classic just had their
data class and I asked them about you
know the you know what did you learn
what the in this case the beats were all
ethnicities in New York so you know what
did you what data did you look at what
did you learn what exciting stories did
you find in the data
and you know one student said well I
learned that there were more people from
Puerto Rico living in New Jersey than in
New York and I learned that from the
Census and I'm thinking if the census
can't tell you that then I don't know
what it can tell you and that's great um
but what was a surprising thing give me
something that shocked you were and it
there wasn't anything right they had all
basically done a pulldown menu for for
the census and came up with tables and
those tables floated into which is
nothing bad about that at all but what
it means is that the story about how a
particular neighborhood came to be the
way it is which requires the census data
joined over decades with regularize
indices about you know this this this
ethnicity being represented all the way
through right and seeing like being able
to find that level of data which exists
for sure but but when they're consulted
to find that level of data and then also
be able to know how they manipulated how
they work with it right and I think some
of that how you manipulated it comes
back to us and maybe not you although it
would be an interesting back and forth
to decide where we teach either way it
has to be taught in a way that the
student says oh this is important I have
to pay attention but for my students I
think finding that data that describes
something is something that they really
need an exposed in a way that they can
make the most use of it thank you um I
was very fascinated by your response
about the role of library and you're all
three of you talking about the physical
library in there and kind of that
passion to access materials and use the
physical environment as we move to this
world that way we'll need to figure out
how to improve search and discovery in a
digital world to think about virtual
shelf browsing to come up with ways to
approximate serendipity however it might
be that was a great conversation how
important is it that we make these
algorithms in these efforts transparent
and open and is that something that's a
transitional phase unload for example
that commercial providers of search
don't make their out
rhythms open and transparent and yet you
use them so how do we have an extra
obligation and libraries to think about
that and to build the trust of our of
our research community in opening up
those those access methods let me jump
in before mark says yes and say no as a
research you know if there's research in
I our information retrieval or
recommendation systems return ensure i
want that to be open and i want to know
how the algorithm works if i'm going to
amazon i did you know it bothers mark
hey Mark used the word humanity didn't
you get mark use the worst humanity
imagine our humanists in this room oh
that is a word that's often invoked will
have bothers people that they don't know
what this freaky algorithm is doing it I
it just does not really bother me so
much that I don't know what lines of
code are powering amazon serendipity
when it shows me some book and if it's
if it's right on you know i may click on
it and i may even buy it and that
probably trainers their algorithm to do
a better job which is really okay with
me and if it does a bad job then i will
laugh at it and I'm not particularly
about it face to be clear so how are
them our products I mean we make
algorithms and they inherit the biases
and whatever that we have right so it's
i'm nots not like a human against
algorithm it's all human right that's
not how I'm I mean I'm worried about and
i overstated the case about needing to
know exactly what an algorithm is doing
what I'm what I'm interested in though
is that is that that idea of serendipity
wasn't in maybe this point is just too
subtle but wasn't embedded in the
original design or layout of the
physical system and yet it arose from
our interaction with it I'm seeing now
that with Google's and whatever that
that those out of a proprietary or not
are not providing me with that Oh moment
right so i can see that there's a gap
and and however research chooses to fill
that gap is is is fine by me what I'm
what I'm slightly concerned about too is
that is that is that
it says what I end up having to tell my
my journalism students right every piece
of digital technology embeds within it a
model of the world and acts as an
argument for that model right so it
reinforces that the model that it has so
like nowadays if you type something into
google and you don't get the things that
you it's you expected you don't say
Google got it wrong you said I must have
done something wrong right because it's
acting as a very strong argument for its
way of thinking about search and all I'm
suggesting is that that we have the
capacity should be sort of think
critically part of this openness and
whatever is our ability to think
critically about about these tools it
doesn't have to be a transparent system
but I should be able to to question it
in a way and think about it as as some
active human expression or a piece of
human ingenuity and to reject the
results and possibly use a competing
perhaps earlier Susan did you want to
just comment on that before we wrap up
by just I'm not sure because um I think
the virtual browsing I can't remember I
feel as if I've experienced some version
of ritual browsing somewhere not at
Columbia somewhere else and I thought it
was it was very helpful and that's all I
have to say for now good very good well
thank you so much
you